[Musique]
le jardin argenté est un espace public
qui s'inscrit dans un maillage globale
des espaces publics à l'échelle de
l'opération d'aménagement de la zac de
moulon il s'inscrit dans un système
global qui est composé de plusieurs
espaces publics qui vont être livrés
prochainement également le parc du
moulon le my la place du lieu de vie le
carré des sciences est également
l'ensemble des voiries et des espaces
publics l'aménagement de ce jardin est
essentiel dans l'animation du campus
urbain de paris saclay il accompagne
l'ouverture de l'école centrale supélec
et offrira également un lieu d'agrément
confortable pour les habitants du
quartier donc ce jardin constitue un
lien naturel entre les étudiants de
l'école centrale et le reste du quartier
leur permettant ainsi d'avoir accès aux
transports en commun qui se
développeront d'abord avec les bus en
site propre et l'ensemble des mobilités
accessible puis à terme le métro qui se
situera luz au nord de ce jardin donc ce
jardin sera équipée de lieux qui
permettent donc de s'installer de lire
de jouer de s'allonger
du mobilier sera prévu pour mais
également de se promener au travers
d'une végétation qui a pu être conservé
cet hiver la plantation des arbres
viendra compléter l'aménagement paysager
du jardin et permettra aux futurs
habitants de profiter pleinement de ce
lieu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]